[Music]
all right and we are live welcome to the
last word with Ibaka sand law Cognito we
are live here in the beautiful Rosen
Shingle Creek what's up how's it going
man we've been enjoying the con so far
it's crazy it's actually really really
cool here if you were a destiny fan at
all like this is your this is like your
Mecca this is like your trip for the
year so it's been really cool meeting a
lot of awesome people everybody's been
really positive so yeah if you didn't
make this trip definitely look next year
this Rosen Shingle Creek Resort is
amazing and huge huge so yeah I'll let
you take Dobbin do you you said it best
I mean this has been truly remarkable
like not even I could have envisioned
how like immense the building is the
location is there's a golf course here
by the way and then just to share volume
of people that are all destiny fans
gamers like that aspect really is mom
glowing so let's get into the con itself
this is day one what's your feelings
what are some standout shadow people
rely for the pool yard we laughing the
proof we give me that last word real
experience but give me some standout
experiences from you so for day one of
Guardian con I mean just the resort
itself like the space is really cool
they've got a couple stages so the
spacing of both is really nice and
honestly just like for me some of the
stance and outs have been the the
creatives all the art people all the
artists and things like those have been
really cool to see and meet and just
like seeing all the different creative
types but also like Bungie sitting right
there in the middle of the whole thing
you have so many booths for playing
invincible and gambit and stuff like
that they are that's probably other ones
like getting to just see a lot of the
bunch of us and how many made the trip
and like how many are here for this it's
just showing some really really cool
love for the community from them which
is great yeah I mean concurrent with you
man I think that the the thing about it
that really separated separates it from
Pascoe
that we've been to is bungees presents
is the fact that it's literally an
intimate feel there right there on the
fraud and accessible ideas there then
the next minute you know you're talking
to like you know Cosmo and you know it's
just that non-stop creative people the
developers that are in the community
just being accessible amongst the floor
and just to scope of it right this is
amazing yeah that's huge I mean they've
got the stage you picture is like I mean
they have one stage which is pretty
massive lots of seats behind it that's
where they've been doing some of the
bigger presentations like the raid belts
from Bungie and the st. Jude's
presentation so those are really cool
and then the other side they have like
more specific topics you've got lore
you've got mental health and things so
it's like they're covering a lot of
things when it comes to content creation
and just like gaming community in
general across a huge spectrum which is
really cool it's not just specialize
like hey we play destiny it's like what
are streamers mental Health's like the
lore of destiny which is like myelin
games and by it's like shot the bike
everybody was awesome shout out some
I've met him myelin games as well we
caught him last night party almost
bought him a drink but not quite this
thing is really cool and it's just names
to faces and shaking hands and people
you've seen in the community it's kind
of just it you don't get to do that and
a lot of things and this is really
really cool to see everybody come
together in one place
absolutely when I think that is you
nailed it and I think ultimately you
realize how large this community truly
is like the thing about it it doesn't
matter for a small content creator a
large content creator it is just like
community man like again I know I'm
biased I know destiny is our favorite
game but at the end of the day I am hard
pressed to find communities that can not
only consistently raised for charity in
a way that they're doing what st. Jude's
and all that stuff but just this
communal come together for positivity
and for the love of this game I haven't
seen such something like that before
no it's really cool to see cuz everybody
you meet is just like genuinely nice
they're happy to be there it's like
everybody's like you know you could I
don't know I haven't been to like III or
other conventions and I'm sure a lot of
them are still pretty positive but you
like you know you're up shoulders or
somebody they're like hey what's up just
like it's all just positive and good
stuff in here it's like the line
situation to get this thing
no the he got it early so he got that
the day early this on day of that is an
organization piece first time in the
resort so we'll give them got working a
couple days I'm checking in I don't know
I like the way the space is set up I'm
not like it would take a little
different organization completely really
really long like separation lines of you
were gonna do that there are ways to but
it's like it could have changed a bit so
but honestly outside of just like
getting the badge it's been amazing the
food in this resort let's let's give it
up to Rose and Shingle y'all Rose and
Shingle Creek like I had no idea this
like you look at the pictures you look
at the hotel until you get here I'm
telling you right now if you guys have
never done Guardian con this is the one
to do we came from or the Tampa Fair we
met there cool don't get me wrong nice
attempt at what they were doing we love
but the energy of it was but this this
is Bri me this is like this is the
experience I mean again you have
everything you want you got your pool
you got you your gym that he didn't make
it but we but you got so many facilities
man and it is immense you got stores
inside like it is almost a
self-contained island you don't need to
leave that's another thing they've got
there is he said they've got everything
here so if you're looking to like just
spend time in one place like the
convention itself is indoors you can
walk from your hotel room through the
lobby to the convention not sweating in
the Florida heat not turning into a
puddle on the way I just like waiting in
line like it's really well done and just
the space is I mean it's always gonna
need more space probably but I was like
they managed the space really well
there's a couple tweaks you might have
for popular spots but I mean overall
this place is an amazing resort like
vacation here would be awesome right
this is a vacation spot without even
Guardian cost you know straight up
vacation and since we did it through
Guardian con like what we got the rooms
for an absolute steal y'all do I want
also can't forget I want to shout out
get Dalian this bro man Kevin do
like all of them well everybody who
responsible for putting this together
again we've been here four years ago
we've seen the growth and to see this
thing trance explode into this is truly
mind-blowing so shout out to those guys
for organizing for me person as far as
to stand out so I would say like okay
God you got a chance to see destiny on
the floor you know we saw the what's our
guy pay no from gamma crater penetrates
yeah big huge integral part of the gamma
team talk to him for a little bit just
about its that's I mean talking it like
what was that like just talking to a dev
about you know just you tell yeah just
like we had this great conversation
about he's like look ask us about gambit
prime and get like what do you think and
we just had this real honest discussion
I'm like look you know I'm on the side
that love prime was cool I like some
things that they tried to do with it you
know there was some things that I still
prefer a standard gambit and then tell
them what you said like as far as your
whole thing was like mine for me it's
just like you almost want kind of
lovechild of both because like prime and
regular game but have different things
and he's just sitting there's like
totally in agreement and like talking
about invasions for me is something I
never thought I would do but like the
hybrid mode of gambit let me have fun in
a way I never expected in in destiny as
I'm not gonna be like I'm not a true
Vanguard like PvP sniper in this file
I'm not that level in PvP but there are
moments when I invade and especially the
new maps I told him was like I like the
new maps right you the mobility or the
cover that you can use and he just I
mean they appreciate that type of
feedback from like the people who play
the game they play their game there's no
question all of them play their game
absent line but when they can sit there
and ask us questions and see what we
think about it it feels really cool to
sit there and have a developer who's
working on the game that you play
actually like just listen to you and say
yeah absolutely or cool or that's a
surprise or any of those things you're
like they work on the game
yeah and I'm talking to them it's like
it's kind of a weird thing for me cuz
like this man's been d3 and talked to
some like this for me is like dude this
is awesome it's awesome and I want you
to elaborate on that now we talked to
what was our guy that we were talking to
this was his first Guardian con and we
were over there I forgot
he said that see yeah yeah now his story
to me was interested because he
basically said he was like in the
community forums and ended up getting a
job at Dylan yeah yeah so I mean a
TMG if you guys don't know dmg Valda
bread memes if you don't know then you
know check Twitter out but Dylan was
really really cool we talked to him and
Catherine she's part of actually the
raid team as well both of you guys were
awesome you've probably seen him both in
the BI Docs and stuff but I mean he said
he was on the bunchy forms an active
person ended up throwing all of stuff in
a car in San Diego driving up taking the
job and just yeah just went for it and I
mean Cosmo if you guys have seen him as
well he's been in the community team a
little longer
he ran a Bungie reddit or the Destiny
reddit so I mean the you see like you
get these awesome stories of like hey I
wish I could work at Mundy and they were
like these were the same stories from
them and that's what's really cool to
talk to them and be like it's like I
wish I could and they're like dude I did
the same thing do it again it's awesome
and I want to get some shout out we sort
a big show shout out to the big show we
saw him don't yeah he's a big dude it's
a big deal it's a big deal well so you
got him I want to shout out all cool guy
and he's just like he fits the bill he
was like he's a cool guy
he's I know that sounds cliche but is
he's just like chill fun guy very nice
fold out plays fall out shout out to you
man shake your hand low no low say no to
rage mr. low know for sure man also like
I mean come on we wiill are passionate
about destiny but that man does more
talking caught like he will he know he's
talked more about destiny than probably
almost anybody I would feel yeah he's up
there for sure but I mean it's been
amazing so the artists like Brian my yo
like I gotta make me bro pieces art yeah
he's his really cool but like not just
him he's just like one of the first ones
we went to but I can go down that whole
row of artists and just like I want
something from all of them and the cool
thing about it is also like I said you
have you have the like I said Bungie
themselves
you've got the community you've got the
fans then you've got people what is
amazing content creators and artists and
and then forget well you know what I
don't think we're forgetting about it's
just a video game like this is also
gaming we've got Borderlands three in
here we've got control remember from 505
games so the cool thing about destiny
that I'm liking
that they're doing is it's almost
inclusive to other deaths like which
I've never seen before to be honest well
they're not it's not like they should be
afraid and no one should it's like
everyone's making their own games but
they're just like the more of support
and that's shadowing out to get a lien
on Bremen and like Kevin again putting
this together and looking for people in
this like in this space of games that
wants to be part of this event I almost
forgot
one of the coolest things coming into
the whole thing is like that whole like
arcade of vintage game like old arcade
games like the old-school NBA Jam I'm
even got like pong he's on fire they got
like like it's just like forget Guardian
come before you even enter the facility
it's just so cool just to see all that
stuff line of it you can literally game
there all day and it's a ton of stuff
it's not just like one or two machines
it's like tons of stuff man yeah what'd
you think about that that was actually
pretty cool to see the arcade it's a
nice way to kind of just get in the
gaming vibe as you're walking in
nostalgic hits as you go but just as
soon as you walk in you just see like
the scale of what's in front of you like
the way they've got everything Bungie is
square in the middle the huge stage off
to lift the meet ups and everything and
then there's a whole another section for
like kind of a lounge area and then
you've got the other stage just so much
cool cool stuff in there it's been it's
been kind of surreal but like one of the
biggest things and shout out to again
like gatholian and bro man and what
they've done the charity streams
everything they put together the number
this year I mean they're over 3.8
million total going to st. Jude's and
st. Jude's has their booth there they've
got like st. Jude's capes which is
really really awesome they're just cool
they're like they're like here but a
really cool thing they have and they
were saying when people go through their
treatments and stuff and or their round
of chemo is done they have a party for
them yeah they'll go and they have like
kind of a VR experience to be part of
that and see that and stuff like that
and that's like that's what this whole
thing is all about it's like we're
gamers we have fun but the like the
whole banner above the entrance that is
good yeah and that's one of the big
that's why this whole thing is here is
like the good that they do for the
community the positivity and then the
charity work that they're able to do by
such an awesome community in this event
that they've
it's like it's hands down like second to
none second and netten to me
you nailed it I think that's why I'm
probably the most proud because again
it's it's gaming yes that's the
forefront but at the end of the day to
see the community come together for such
a positive thing for kids in need and
it's just that whole production of it
makes me proud to be a destiny fan and
it really doesn't get any better man but
yeah this is day one experiences man
it's still we still got more kind left
more things to do more meetups but we
just want to give you guys like a little
behind the scene and dude obviously do
something for you guys who's never been
gotta come to you've got to come to
Guardian next year if you if you didn't
make it this year make a trip out of it
get here dare it's early to check in go
to Universal like make it a little
vacation something like that but get out
here if you like the game have fun if
there's people in the community you know
so many of them are here it's like and
there's not always everybody can make it
but as many as you might want to see if
you're gonna see so many more that you
don't even know and meet some really
cool people absolutely man you already
here first for the landlord Cognito you
bounce it's the last word but ah yeah
but you couldn't set any better I mean
I'm absolutely having a ball I cannot
wait to see more do more you know I'm
saying we got to get online tomorrow for
some bungee action I need some gambit
corn oh the shadow keeper video it's
like we were kind of far away and didn't
see all of it but man it looks September
can't get here so no that's all I can
say it's like it looks sick bro Bunji
gameplay tremendous skyboxes I mean Oh
Harris was in the building today yeah I
wasn't in Marla she's here like her
voice when she does Harris is like on
another level is so cool just do you
like talk to me like oh you're really
cool really nice and then she goes to
that voice and you like did you have
event again Guardian Khan gave one
complete whip my Manny boxes have been
for years
Oh too long good to see you again
brother we hugged it out we shared a
drink I bought him a drink we had
chalices brother we at we at Calais
chalice go check out the Twitter those
margaritas are like the size of my head
zag y'all ready have it so we're gonna
do all cute we're gonna do our normal Q
we actually can do it we can do problems
out of any lag of delay no bail so I'm
gonna let you set it off and I will you
close it out all right well you guys
know where to find me it's Eve on ttis
of course this thing's gonna be up later
you sir as well of course Lord cockney
jewelry no it's gonna be up on Iowa
podcast later and this is this will be
the last word